et pour en parler nous sommes avec
catherine grosse économiste spécialiste
de l'inde à l'université à gustave
eiffel à paris bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
alors la première question que je vais
vous poser c'est pourquoi une nouvelle
loi sur la citoyenneté en inde je
rappelle ce que c'est ça qui a mis le
feu aux poudres en ce moment tout à fait
alors il ya eu en fait il ya plusieurs
réformes qui sont faites au fur et à
mesure pour essayer de refaire un
réformé un peu les critères de
nationalité et donc il ya une première
étape qui s'est fait dans l'assam pour
lutter contre des migrants illégaux et
une deuxième étape donc été sa plaque
sur la nationalité qui avait au dire du
gouvernement en tout cas une visée
humanitaire puisque elle s'adressait à
accès elle permettait d'accélérer
l'accès à la citoyenneté indienne pour
toutes les minorités religieuses du
pakistan de l'afghanistan et du
bangladesh
donc de fait toutes les tous les
individus tous les ressortissants de ces
pays sauf les musulmans et le
gouvernement disait que c'était normal
puisqu'ils sont majoritaires mais en
fait le problème c'est que cette loi a
été interprétée par beaucoup d'indiens
comme étant une nouvelle mesure
vexatoire qui s'allonge qui s'ajoutent à
une très très longue liste de mesures
vexatoires contre les musulmans puisque
le parti au pouvoir c'est un parti qui
essentiellement qui dans l'idéologie
plonge ses racines dans windows
installer un suprématie hindous et donc
depuis le début des mandats maudit en
fait il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de
mesures qui ont été perçus par les
musulmans contre eux et là cette refonte
de la citoyenneté indienne est perçue
par les musulmans comme une tentative de
les reléguer dans une catégorie de
citoyens de seconde zone et donc ça a
provoqué effectivement beaucoup de
manifestations depuis décembre qui l'
ont donné lieu carrément à des violences
du coup certains médias évoquent
l'orchestration de ces violences par des
nationalistes hindous au conditionnel
qui qui est responsable de ces
affrontements selon vous alors il ya une
chose qu'il faut bien avoir à l'esprit
c'est qu'en fait dès le premier
mandat a maudit dès sa première élection
en 2015
il ya eu des espèces de groupes de
vigiles en thèse qui se sont eux qui ont
émergé sont des groupes de citoyens qui
se font fort de faire respecter la loi
tel qu'il pense qu'elle est ou tel qui
pensent qu'elle devrait être
c'est un espèce de milice en fait et qui
par exemple attaques des camions qui
sont supposés transporter de la viande
bovine
mais qui sont en fait conduit par des
musulmans par des basses castes il ya
aussi des milices qui a une rumeur comme
quoi les musulmans essayer de séduire
les filles indo pour les convertir donc
a eu des milices qui s'attaquait au
couple en plein jour et donc en fait le
gouvernement moi dit a beaucoup laissé
la bride sur le cou de ses milices et à
laisser s'épanouir une espèce d'impunité
de ces groupes de civils auto constitué
et donc à une espèce d'atmosphère qui se
développe en inde ou en fait les
citoyens peuvent se saisir eux mêmes de
la justice ou de ce qui se passait de la
justice et s'attaquer impunément à
certaines minorités en l'occurrence les
musulmans et donc c'est pas dans ce
contexte c'est un peu attendu qu
effectivement il y ait des affrontements
intercommunautaires qui deviennent
violents et comment on peut les appeler
ces groupes de civils et rebelles n'ont
eu comme mon nom du tout céder des
citoyens qui considèrent qu'ils rendent
la justice qu'il faut ajuster ses
milices en réalité ils rendent la
justice eux-mêmes
oui alors qu'ils compensent est la
justice war alors l'entendue à la
présidente du parti du congrès sonia
gandhi réclament la démission du premier
ministre narendra modi membre du parti
nationaliste hindou quels sont les
enjeux de pouvoir derrière ce conflit
religieux et sont à mon avis très
important en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que le gouvernement maudit a beaucoup
son premier mandat et est très centré
sur des réformes économiques d'accord
qui tendait un pas faire oublier peut
effectivement les racines du bjp c'est
quand même vraiment la suprématie
hindoue donc il ya eu des mesures
vexatoires il ya eu des choses pas très
agréable pour les musulmans mais le
deuxième mandat ce qui est vraiment
frappant c'est qu'en fait l'économie de
l'inde va pas très bien
il ya un taux de chômage qui est très
élevé et il ya un taux de croissance qui
fait be est donc là il ya une
accélération du programme de clivage des
communautés de la part du gouvernement
et donc en fait puisque ça traduit c'est
que maudit s'appuie sur ces clivages
pour imposer effectivement son pouvoir
politique
donc les enjeux sont relativement fort
en fait la communauté autour on a vu que
du coup ces affrontements ont fait
beaucoup de blessés beaucoup de morts
également à ce que la communauté
internationale peut agir vis-à-vis de de
cesser l'affrontement qui deviennent de
plus en plus sérieux en inde
alors oui et non si vous voulez
évidemment la communauté internationale
peuvent pas condamné mais je vais vous
donner un exemple
en 2002 il y avait des programmes anti
musulmans au gujarat dont le ministre en
chef était maudit et qui a fait des
milliers de victimes qui est un peu du
même style que ce qu'on voit à d et en
fait il avait été très condamné par la
communauté internationale est en fait
comme audi a été élu premier ministre de
l'inde
la communauté internationale a un peu
c'est un peu pincé le nez mais
finalement on a laissé faire a laissé
faire donc en fait il ya quand même
aussi un problème et puis aussi en fait
aussi l'idée que après tout ces
problèmes appartiennent à l'inde
et c'est dû à quoi faisait des enjeux
économiques trop important encore une
fois il ya des enjeux économiques qui
sont qui sont certainement important m
merci beaucoup 4 immo d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur à l'université paris ii et
spécialiste de l'inde à l'université et
just have fl à paris